les frigos ne sont pas encore
complètement vide mais ils font peine à
voir
pour stéphane leconte ont 20 ans de
carrière chéri et mme becker il n'a
jamais connu périodes plus creuses
aujourd'hui dans les chambres froides
n'y a pas grand chose et ça c'est depuis
dix jours c'est vraiment le minimum est
ce assez pour assurer toute la partie
plateaux repas parce que sur la commande
toute la partie événementielle on n'a
quasiment pas de commande depuis que les
rassemblements de plus de 1000 personnes
sont interdits dans les lieux confinés
en france le traiteur de la région
parisienne dit avoir perdu neuf cent
mille euros de chiffre d'affaires en
quelques jours va pas reprendre en port
dû elle même son de cloche pour ces deux
organisateurs d'événements tous les
rassemblements planifié par leur agence
jusqu'en mai ont été annulés ou reportés
imaginez du jour au lendemain ne plus
avoir du tout de travail ne plus avoir
du tout de choses à organiser ou à
vendre ça s'est arrêté du jour images
très nettes
la question c'est combien de temps on
peut tenir dans cette situation où il
n'y a plus rien s'est il ya toute une
filière
quitte à l'arrêt brusque du jour au
lendemain avec les prestataires les
partenaires les intermittents les et
qu'est ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'on peut
tenir un mois est ce qu'on peut tenir
deux mois est ce qu'on peut tenir 3 - ça
va être ça la question
nous sommes au tout début de cette
épidémie il faut être très clair lucide
et français ne sont donc pas au bout de
leurs peines prévient le président
emmanuel macron qui cherche aussi à
rassurer les citoyens 85 % de celles et
ceux qui seront positifs aux copies 19
et qui donc auront ce virus auront une
forme bénigne de celui ci et que donc la
lucidité la transparence dont nous
faisons preuve doit aussi s'accompagner
de beaucoup de calme
mais restez calme n'est pas chose simple
pour les habitants des régions plus
durement touchée par le corona virus
comme ici dans l'oise l'un des
épicentres de la contamination
ici les mesures imposées sont plus
strictes les écoles sont fermées pour
les deux prochaines semaines au moins
dans toute la france ce sont plus de 300
mille élèves qui sont privés de classe
isabelle ne veut pas céder à la panique
et continue de faire ses courses en
portant ce masque de papier un peu usé
son dernier et elle le garde
précieusement puisqu'elle n'en trouve
plus en pharmacie il est désarmé face à
tout ce temps j'ai mon père qui était
touché qui à l'hôpital de damien alors
la fiev et le yacht pourvu qu'on arrive
à le sauver puis la 83e quand on
reviendra une situation normale je pense
que justement on va encore plus se
rassembler pour relancer l'économie les
relations le contact pour marquer un peu
la fin comme à la libération en
attendant la france dénombre encore de
nouveaux cas surtout des nains assurent
les autorités
mais qui chaque jour rapproche le
spectre confinement élargi ici marie-eve
bédard à radio canada paris